all right awesome well i was wondering
maybe if first you would mind just kind
of telling me a little bit about your
fashion line i was looking everything up
and kind of how you got involved in
fashion and
sure
um i started with one t-shirt um
in like 2002 and i just made it for fun
just for friends
and then my friend charlotte ronson had
opened a store
so just kind of for fun we sold it at
the store
and bloomington bloomingdale's buyer saw
it and so bloomingdale's was technically
like our first real account so
we did well kind of right away um
and then it just sort of expanded from
there and
we got into like you know silk and
leather and jackets and
kind of not just graphics but i'm
actually taking a break
from doing all that right now because of
the show and other things i wanted to do
so i'm kind of happy with how it all
went but it just felt like okay
production's kind of a nightmare it's
taking up all my time
um and i love what i did and i just
thought like okay it's just nice to kind
of
end it on a good note
yeah
i always have the chance to go back but
for right now that's kind of all i
wanted to say
about
sophomore and what that was it felt like
it was time to move on nate when were
you first approached about doing this
show
um
uh one of my best friends her name is
amanda silverman she's been pharrell's
publicist for like
i don't know 15 years 10 years wow so
i've always known him and
i've been approached about doing like
other tv tv shows right
and that sort of freaked me out
and then
at the same time people kept talking
about uh
how youtube is doing this like
initiative to kind of get people to
watch youtube and i was like you know
what that sounds
more like something i would do
so just on a whim um
my friend amanda emailed him i was like
give chrissy a show literally and he was
like okay
and then um
and then we just sort of like all
concepted the show together it was like
a big kind of collaboration between us
i am mother and then the director shawna
bruto he kind of came up with
the real like meat of the show like the
pee-wee's playhouse stuff and having it
more have a personality i kind of
thought it was gonna be like
really martha stewart style like i'm at
a table there's like someone next to me
you know so
yeah it came out
much more
interesting and
creative than what i thought originally
style what was your vision kind of going
into it what were the things that you
really wanted the show to be about
um
i watch a lot of that like do it
yourself like everything from like how
to get like blood off my sheets
in my house like i
it's just so cool that you can see
anything and i found with the fashion
stuff i i thought that the videos i was
seeing were a little harder
like um
i the stuff i do i want to be like done
in five minutes you know i don't want to
like
have a whole process so
the original idea was i'm always like
making stuff
and um
yeah so we wanted it to be like really
like anyone could do it like
there's one episode where you put like
nail polish on your keys so like they
look cool and you can wear them as a
necklace like
everyone has keys everyone has nail
polish you know stuff like that
what do you feel like you've gotten out
of like being a part of youtube as
opposed to before when you were
approached by like tv episodes
um
i mean it's still so new we're like kind
of finding our audience like i think
right now it's all like a lot of
pharrell fans which is really funny
have major crushes on him
so funny like oh my god you're sitting
next to him
the dazzling issues
but i think like moving forward like we
didn't send that to her it'd be so cool
if like we could start to see like what
other people are making and the show
kind of evolves into more like of an
interactive
thing where i could like show photos and
show like um
you know other products or other things
that other people are making
what has it been like to work with
pharrell
oh my god he's so cute like so
obsessed i mean i've always loved him
and
he's just like a nice sweet like
kind of like white energy like just
you just like want to smile around him
like he's just so sweet
um
yeah and also like i'm like such a nerdy
fan of his too
if i still think about it too much like
it would freak me out but yeah he's like
yes
well how have you i was reading some
articles and they were saying that your
apartment used to be called club chrissy
and how have you kind of brought all
those elements about yourself into this
channel because it feels so unique and
it feels like it's very you
right well i think
you know living in new york like you
don't have a lot of you know our friends
don't have big places to hang out at and
when i moved into that apartment it was
like this
it was like 2 000 square feet commercial
space like which is why it wasn't that
expensive i mean i had like
a bunch of roommates and um
it was just like i just i don't like to
be
out that often like i don't i don't want
to like hang out at a bar restaurant
like i just it's important for me
to be able like being at home and like i
know that sounds crazy but that never
happens
really like never
you can't have more than like a handful
of people over and even my friends that
do big clips like they just don't
entertain because
it's just not what people do here
so i think that's why it was so special
was like literally like people would
buzz as if it was like you know a club
would be walking by it was on saint
mark's which
is kind of like the armpit of the east
village and
there's always like a neighborhood for
one reason or another so it was just so
nice that we were able to have that um
and i missed that a lot
like just that
being like without a lot of music and
like
a conversation i'm obsessed with like
talking to people and
um yeah so i think like we tried to
recreate that with the show
it's a little harder with this show
because you can't really have like five
people or else it would be like the view
yeah i don't think it would work but the
one-on-one thing
and i feel like i'm kind of just by
nature like i'm like an interviewer like
i'm inquisitive and
i want to like learn more about people
and stuff like that so that was always
it always felt like that at my house
like when people came over anyway we i
tried to do another show at that
apartment called in bed with chrissy
where
we'd lay in bed
um but yeah that never wound up working
i pre youtube
what are some things we can look forward
to on your show
there's so many cool things um
well
one of my best friends drea di mateo she
was in um
sopranos i was really happy that she was
in town shooting
she has a little daughter that comes on
the show that's awesome
um pamela love which is great uh
so happy that she was involved my mom
who's an astrologer
does the whole thing with me so yeah
there's lots of good stuff
neat well let me see if we
yeah i think honestly i think that was
about it for all of my questions we all
we covered everything so well is there
anything you want to add or any
questions you have about this
i don't think so
yeah um if you think of anything else
now you have my skype i know now i'm
just going to call you up all the time
show you all my do-it-yourself projects
that i've done
um yeah that's something we wanted to do
on the show too was like skype with
people and like so that other people
could show off their things but you know
when it's so new we had to like wait for
all that so
who do you think your dream guest would
be to have on the show
that's a good question and
i've been thinking a lot about um like
other areas besides fashion like it
would be so cool we could get like a
like a chef
or
just learn how to make something like
really outside the box
but
even think like oh wow i can do that at
home um
uh
i'm thinking of like a sh i don't know
like anthony bourdain how about that
that'd be cool
be really cool that would be cool yeah
and who came up with the idea of having
the little pigeon and the fish who's
always eating in the corner
and that's a sweet hand
his name's sean
he's the director that's all his idea
i like them i like the pigeon very much
we're in new york right yes
well this has been awesome thank you so
much for doing this
it was nice to meet you oh it's nice
meeting you i'll definitely let you know
when everything's coming out
okay cool okay and good luck with
everything
you youtube okay bye